today I'm going to give you a quick
rundown of everything you need to know
before you watch what if season 2 the
new animated Marvel series that's
releasing on December 22nd 2023 don't
worry this video is spoiler-free so you
can watch it without ruining any
surprises from season 2 but there will
be mentions from the first season of the
show now it's time to know before you
[Music]
go Marvel's what if is an animated
series that explores the Multiverse and
shows us what would happen if some key
moments in the MCU were different each
episode focuses on a different scenario
such as what if Captain Carter were the
First Avenger or what if kilmonger
rescued Tony Stark the series is
narrated by uatu The Watcher a cosmic
being who observes the Multiverse but
cannot interfere the first season has
nine episodes each with its own twist
and consequences here are some of the
highlights in episode one Peggy Carter
takes the super soldier serum instead of
Steve Rogers becoming Captain Carter she
fights against Hydra and Red Skull who
uses the tesak to summon an
interdimensional creature feature Steve
Rogers Pilots a suit of armor made by
Howard Stark similar to Iron Man the
episode ends with Captain Carter being
transported to the present day by the
Tesseract where she meets Nick Fury in
episode two tchala becomes Star-Lord
instead of Peter Quill joining the
ravagers and becoming a galactic hero he
convinces Thanos to abandon his plan of
wiping out half of the universe and
reunites with his father tachaka he also
encounters ego The Living Planet and
Quill's father who is still looking for
his son the episode ends with ego
finding quill who works at a dear Queen
and hinting at a Sinister plot in
episode three The Avengers are killed
one by one before they can assemble by a
mysterious assassin it's revealed that
the Killer is Hank Pim who blames shield
for the death of his daughter hope who
was also a shield agent he's stopped by
Nick Fury who reveals that he's
recruiting Heroes to form a new team of
Avengers in episode 4 Doctor Strange
loses his heart instead of his hands in
a car accident meaning that he loses his
girlfriend Christine Palmer he becomes
obsessed with reversing her death and
uses the eye of agamotto to travel back
in time and change the outcome however
he learns that her death is an absolute
point in time meaning that it cannot be
altered without destroying the fabric of
reality he ignores the warnings of the
ancient one and datu and absorbs the
power of various mystical beings to
become more powerful he eventually
succeeds in Saving Christine but at the
cost of dooming his Universe to Oblivion
in episode 5 a zombie outbreak occurs on
Earth caused by a Quantum virus that
infects Janet vany in the quantum realm
which spreads to the rest of the world a
small group of survivors including
Spider-Man wasp Banner Bucky Barnes AO
Sharon Carter and happy Hogan try to
find a cure and a way to contact a
potential sanctuary in wakanda they
discover that Vision has been keeping
the zombie Wanda maximoff alive and
feeding her human flesh including tala's
leg they managed to escape with the help
of Scott Lang's head which is kept in a
jar by Vision they head to a condo where
they hope to use a satellite to
broadcast the cure to the world however
they're unaware that Thanos who is also
a zombie has arrived in wakanda with
five Infinity Stones and is about to get
the sixth one from Vision in episode 6
Eric kilmonger saves Tony Stark from the
10 Rings attack in Afghanistan
preventing him from becoming Iron Man he
becomes Stark's trusted Ally and helps
him develop new weapons using vibranium
he also kills James rh's ant toala and
Frames the latter's death on ulyses claw
he then betrays and kills Stark as well
as claw and presents his body to the
wakandans earning their trust he then
leads a war against the US using Stark's
drones which are secretly powered by
vibranium he becomes the new protector
of wakanda and the episode ends with
Sher and pepper pots teaming up to
expose kilmonger crimes and stop his
plans in episode seven Thor is an only
child as Loki was returned to the frost
Giants as a baby he grows up to be a
party-loving prince who decides to have
a massive celebration on Earth while
Odin is in his Odin sleep he attracts
the attention of various aliens and
Cosmic beings who join his party and
cause chaos on the planet he also meets
Jane Foster who tries to contact shield
and warn them of the Potential Threat
Shield resorts to calling Captain Marvel
who engages in a fight with Thor the
fight is interrupted by frga who wakes
up from her sleep and scolds Thor for
his behavior Thor apologizes and cleans
up his mess and decides to pursue a
relationship with Jane the episode ends
with a Twist though aatu is shocked to
see Ultron who has vision's body and all
six Infinity Stones arriving on Earth
with an army of drones in episode 8
Ultron succeeds in uploading his
Consciousness into vision's body and
obtains the Mind Stone he then proceeds
to wipe out the Avengers and launch a
nuclear attack that kills most of
humanity he then faces Thanos who has
the other five Infinity Stones and
easily kills him and takes the stones he
becomes the most powerful being in the
universe and destroys all life on every
planet he visits he then becomes aware
of Wu's presence and breaks through the
barriers of the Multiverse he starts to
hunt down uatu who tries to escape and
find a way to stop him uatu decides to
break his oath and interferes by asking
Doctor Strange Supreme for help in
episode 9 uatu forms a team of Heroes
from different universes called the
Guardians of the Multiverse he recruits
Captain Carter Star-Lord tala party Thor
killmonger Gamora and Doctor Strange
Supreme he gives them a plan to
infiltrate ultron's universe and steal
the Infinity Stones from him using a
device made by Gamora and Tony star the
team manages to distract Ultron and
remove his stones but kilmonger betrays
them and tries to take the stones for
himself he is opposed by Ultron and the
two villains fight over the stones
creating a stalemate Doctor Strange
Supreme uses his magic to contain them
in a pocket Dimension where they will be
locked in an eternal struggle uatu
Returns the heroes to their respective
universes and also gives Black Widow a
new home in the universe where the
Avengers had fallen and Loki had invaded
Earth the episode ends with a
post-credit scene where Captain Carter
finds the Hydra stomper armor that
contains a mysterious passenger likely
Steve Rogers next up other things you
may need to remember are that the Novae
is the intergalactic military and police
force of the Nova Empire led by an
individual holding the rank of Nova
Prime Harold Joseph happy Hogan is the
head of security of Stark Industries and
one of Tony Stark's closest friends The
Grandmaster is the ruler of sakar who
has a fascination with gaming and
manipulating ating lesser life forms
there's a run of Marvel Comics called
Avengers 16002 in which the Marvel
Superheroes exist in the Elizabethan era
in these Comics the heroes must fight to
save their Universe when faced with the
destruction of their world by a
mysterious Force the 10 Rings is a
clandestine criminal and terrorist
organization founded by juu Wen Wu in
the Middle Ages by the 21st century the
10 Rings became involved in Terrorist
activities across the globe in 2024
following W Wu's death during the Battle
of Tallow the organization was taken
over by his daughter juj Ling kahori is
a young Mohawk woman who discovered the
tesak transformed a lake in the henani
Confederacy into a gateway to the Stars
leading her on a quest to discover her
power and there you have it everything
you need to know before you see what if
season 2 if you're a fan of the MCU or
if you're just curious about how things
will play out following the first season
you definitely don't want to miss this
series don't forget to like And
subscribe or check out the video on your
screen for some more of my
[Music]
content